JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Good morning, friends!
Good morning.
There we go.
I hope everybody's doing well.
It's great to see you
all bright and early
on day two of I/O '15.
How many folks made it
to the party last night?
Yeah.
Good times?
I thought so.
Yeah.
So if you made to the party,
and so many of you did,
thank you again for
showing up so early.
My name's Jonathan Alferness.
I'm vice president of
product management at Google,
and I lead up our mobile
display ads products.
I have here with me my good
friend Scott Huffman vice
president of engineering, and
he leads up our mobile search
engineering efforts.
Today we're going to spend
about 40 minutes talking
to you about the world
of apps, app discovery,
and how to really grow your
own audience through the tools
that we're providing.
We're going to talk about this
from an organic perspective,
and also from a
paid perspective.
Then we're going to talk
about some of the tools
that we're providing to help
you analyze the performance
and analyze your
user acquisitions.
There are a ton of apps
available in the App
and the Play Stores today.
About a million-- actually,
more than a million
apps in both of those locations.
And if you think
about this, this
presents an enormous challenge
to mobile app developers,
right?
You need to stand
out from the crowd.
You need to get noticed.
You need to drive
usage of your app.
And the sheer volume of apps
out there is not the only hurdle
that you face, but bringing
users into your app
and engaging them time and time
again is another challenge.
And you see the
other stat behind me,
where literally
a quarter of apps
are downloaded, installed
on users' phones,
and yet never even run once.
So there's a lot of
waste left in the system.
Users are spending more and
more time in mobile apps.
This is adding up to
over 30 hours per month
being spent in
mobile applications.
And what we're see thing is
it's some of this engagement
is long periods of time
spent in game, but some of it
is through tiny slices of
time that really add up.
Users are pulling their mobile
phones out of their pockets
to interact, to reach
for information,
to make things happen even in
the real world, over 150 times
a day.
We think about these
as micro-moments.
Think about it.
You're standing at
the train platform.
You're waiting for the next
commuter train to come.
You pull out your phone, and
you start to work on a task.
You start to work on something
that you needed to do.
But then the train
comes, and you've
got to get in, so you
kind of just, quick,
shut down the phone, put
it back in your pocket,
and climb in the train.
When you get off, you
want to be able to pick up
that task again.
Your day is filled with all
of these slivers of moments
where you can interact
with your mobile devices.
Another example.
You're waiting in line to
pick up a cup of coffee.
You probably pull your
mobile phone back out,
and you want to resume that
task where you left off.
The reason mobile apps
work so well in this space
is that they don't have to
worry about connectivity.
They can save state,
they can provide you
with clean rich UIs,
and they're right there
to be accessed on
your home screen.
So all this time adds up.
And it adds up to now
over 30 hours per month
spent in mobile applications.
And users are using more and
more mobile apps over time.
In fact, the latest
stat indicates
that 36 is the number of apps
that the average American has
on her cell phone.
And, as I mentioned a few
moments ago, a quarter of those
are left completely unused.
We've been out
talking to friends,
talking to users
around the globe,
really trying to
understand more about how
folks are fitting apps
into their daily life.
And I'd like to take you
through one of these stories
to sort of illustrate the
power of mobile applications.
So this is our friend Christian.
This is a true story.
Christian is a
young professional.
He lives in Philadelphia.
And he has a younger brother.
And his younger brother
recently started running.
As with most sibling
relationships,
they have a bit of
a sibling rivalry,
and so Christian is very eager
to go running with his brother
as well and show him that
he can do him one better.
So 5:00 AM, Christian's brother
shows up at Christian's house.
Sounds like about the
time my kids wake up,
which is a little
early to be running.
But anyway, his brother
shows up at the house,
and his brother pulls
out his mobile phone,
and he starts configuring
his running app.
He's downloaded a running
app that helps coaching him,
driving him to be a
better and better runner.
And Christian
thinks, well, dammit,
I can't be one-upped
by my brother.
So he pulls out
his mobile phone,
and he wants his
own running app.
But Christian isn't going
to sit there and use
the same running
app as his brother.
He's unique, he's
his own person,
and because it's a
rivalry, he does a search,
and he starts looking for
the right kind of running app
for him.
He finds a site with
the top 10 running apps,
and he peruses them.
And he finds that there's
this Nike+ running app,
which really,
really sings to him,
because he's always been
an avid Nike customer.
And he has one of those
pairs of Nike sneakers
that have the
little chips in them
so they can actually track
his pacing and running.
And this happens every day.
Thousands upon
thousands of times.
Users need an application to
service some need for them.
They have to make almost
a split second decision
with a little bit
of information.
But for Christian,
this app has now
become an integral
part of his life.
It sits there on
his home screen,
and he uses it every day.
Think about the power of the
connection that was just built
between Nike and Christian.
Discoverability is the
first of these challenges.
How do you get your
app to really stand out
from the crowd?
And today, as app developers,
you're doing a lot of work.
You're worrying about
optimizing your listings.
You've got to create
beautiful videos,
get them out there,
get them published,
get users to watch them.
You probably want to
optimize your keywords
so that you can easily be
found in searches on these Play
stores.
Many of you realize that you
should also extend your reach
by paying for app promotion.
And then you
probably have to deal
with a variety of
social channels.
This is an awful lot of
work, and at Google we're
really leaning in to make
this as easy as possible,
to really cut through as much
of this as we can for you.
So let's talk a little
bit about the assets
that Google has to bear
to bring to the solution
to really facilitate app
discovery for all of you.
It really comes down
to the fact that we
have a large variety,
a heterogeneous set,
of different properties
and platforms
that users are interacting
with on a daily basis--
on a minutely basis.
And so across Search, and
the Play Store, and the AdMob
in-app network,
and YouTube, we can
help users connect
with apps as they're
going about their daily life.
And we're working on a
whole variety of tools
to help you connect with
users at the right moments,
as they're looking
for these solutions
to install on their phone.
We understand that,
for app developers,
it is not an Android-only world.
And I want to make sure that all
of you understand this as well.
From our perspective,
we are absolutely
committed to bringing
these solutions
to life across platforms,
across both iOS and AdMob.
Because, for all
of you, you need
to grow the largest
audience possible.
And if we limit to
one platform, you're
not going to be able to do this.
This is an ongoing
commitment for everything
that we're doing in
this mobile apps space.
Now I'd like to welcome
Scott Huffman come up
on stage to talk us
through what we're
doing on the organic
side of the world,
to really help with
discovery and engagement.
SCOTT HUFFMAN: Thanks, Jonathan.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Scott, and I'm
one of the leads
in the search team at Google.
And, in particular, I have
the really fantastic job
of leading up our
mobile search efforts.
And over the last
couple years we've
been very focused
on how can we take
the great content and the
great services that all of you
are creating your apps and
make those a first order
part of the Google Search
experience for our users?
Now, Jonathan talked about
the hard, hard problems
that I think all of you
face in this apps world.
First of all, out
of all those million
apps that are out
there how in the world
do users find out about your
app when they have a need,
understand that your
app is something
they can meet their
need, and decide
to put that app on their phone?
Even once you get
through that hurdle,
we all understand-- and Jonathan
gave some of the stats--
that you're not done
yet, because users
forget your app is there.
They don't really
understand all the things
that your app can do for them.
And a lot of times
it sits unused.
So how do you get users to
reengage once the app is there?
Now, for us and Google
and the Search team,
this actually sounds like
kind of a familiar problem.
We've seen this one before.
If we go back in time, way
back to ancient history,
in 1998, here is a graph
of the number of websites
that were out there.
And there were about a
million websites in 1998.
Lots of great things,
obviously-- there
was huge growth to lead
to this million websites.
But if you were creating
a new web application,
it was very, very difficult
for you to get discovered.
Say that you had a fantastic
collection of cookie recipes,
and you wanted to put that up.
And, in particular,
maybe you just
have the most fantastic
chocolate chip cookie recipes.
How in the world would
people find your site?
You could put yourself
into web directories,
you could try word
of mouth, and really
trying to generate
some buzz, but it's
very difficult for a user who
says to themselves, "I really
need an organic chocolate
chip cookie recipe to bake,"
to find you.
And then along came Google
and other search technologies,
and it really changed the
equation pretty dramatically,
where now all of
a sudden users who
needed that organic chocolate
chip cookie recipe-- that's not
very easy to say, by the way--
could put that into the box,
and if your site had the
relevant best chocolate chip
cookie recipes out
there, it would come up,
users would discover it,
and as users used that, it
would come up more and more.
And so we saw an explosion where
we went from a million websites
to over a billion websites with
just even more dramatic growth
because it enabled the
long tail of everyone who
wanted to create content
services on the web
to be discovered, not
just in a directory,
but in a needs-based way
where users could find you
by expressing their need.
Now here's another graph.
I didn't go backwards
in the slide deck,
I actually went forward, but
the graph looks familiar.
This is the number of
apps in the Play Store,
and, gee, it looks
familiar, doesn't it?
We've had, on the one
hand amazing growth
over the last few years
to get to a million apps.
And on the other hand, maybe
there's a lot further to go,
and a lot more apps,
a lot more content
and services, that
can be created,
if we can allow users
to find those things.
I want to submit to you that
Google Search is a fantastic
place for your app
to be discovered
and for users to be able
to tap into the things
that you're creating.
And, lest people
wonder about this,
in fact what we're
seeing at Google
is that mobile users are
in fact coming to Google
search expressing needs many,
many millions of times a day.
And we're seeing
incredible growth in that.
So here's just one stat that
shows that-- that more Google
searches now are taking
place on mobile phones
than on laptop and desktop
computers in places like the US
and Japan and many
other countries.
And this is just accelerating.
Users don't just tap on app
icons; they come to Google
and they express a need.
And we want to bring your apps
to them when they do that.
Now, our solution
to this problem,
and the way you could
tap into Google Search,
is something that we
call app indexing.
And app indexing is
a pretty simple idea.
What you do is, basically,
you change your app
to add deep linking capability.
Deep links are
basically URLs or URIs
that point to each of the
different pieces of content
or individual services
inside of your app.
And we have a lot of help
here at the conference
and online to help you do that.
We have folks giving
box talks-- in fact,
there's one right
after this talk--
that goes into kind of the nuts
and bolts of how you do this.
We have folks kind of manning a
help desk out here, and so on.
After you add deep
links to your app.
There are a few
simple choices you
have for publishing your
app's deep links to Google.
And then, on the Google side, we
do basically what we always do.
We take those deep links and
we add that to our index,
so that our index now not only
contains content and services
from the web, but
also from your app.
And then we apply our
set of ranking algorithms
to surface your app,
and in particular
the individual pieces
inside of your apps
that are most relevant
for a user's query
when users come along
with those needs.
Now, even before any
of this app indexing
stuff, of course, if people
come to Google Search and ask
for apps, we're going to give
them the best apps of the kind
that they ask for.
So, for example, if a
user comes along and asks
for cooking apps,
Google Search is
going to bring up a nice list of
some of the best cooking apps.
This is something that we've
been doing for a while,
and one thing people
may not realize
is that, in fact, there is a
fair amount of app installation
that flows through
the Google search box,
in addition to what's coming
through the Play Store.
But more often,
people come to Google
and they ask for
things that they need.
They don't know if
they need an app,
they just know that they need
animal-shaped cookie ideas.
And who hasn't needed that?
And what happens if
the user, for example,
doesn't have the
Pinterest app today?
Starting from this side,
if the user says to Google
"animal-shaped cookie ideas,"
in addition to content from
the web and other apps, Google
actually offers an installation
offer for apps that have
great content about that.
In this case, one
of the apps that
has great content about the
animal-shaped cookie ideas
is the Pinterest app.
Once a user taps
that install button,
they go through the
Play Store install flow,
and when the app
is installed, you
can see in the middle screen
here not just an open button,
but that green continue button.
And when the user taps
on that continue button,
it in fact takes them not just
to the top of the Pinterest
app, but straight into the
content that they asked for.
In this case, a lovely page full
of animal-shaped cookie ideas.
And so the user has
gone all the way
through from discovering
the app installing the album
and then getting to the
content that they were
looking for inside of that.
Now once your app is
installed, then you
can drive re-engagement
through those deep links
that you've provided to Google.
And whether users are
looking, in these examples,
for things like a restaurant,
a craft idea, a movie, or any
of the other zillion things that
people come to Google every day
to search for-- if your
app has relevant content,
and it is ranked in the
list here, it'll come up.
So you see here some restaurant
related apps, the Etsy craft
app, some movie related
apps, and so on,
that allow users, by
expressing their need,
to come back to your
app again and again.
Now probably people have
heard-- because we've
talked about it a lot
over time-- that Google
uses hundreds of signals
that come together to drive
our ranking algorithms.
And by making your app
content available-- visible,
basically-- to Google, that
content and the characteristics
of your app are able to
influence the ranking
and to help users find that
app at the appropriate times.
Now, that all sounds great.
Or at least I'm hoping
it sounds great,
because I'm trying to give you
the best sales pitch for app
indexing that I can.
But how do we know that
any of this stuff works?
One tool that we have
is something that's
called the search console.
And back in the day, back
in my 1998-type graph,
this tool-- and actually,
more recently than that,
the tool was called
Webmaster Tools.
In fact we've not only renamed
it Search Console to get away
from the idea that is
just for webmasters,
but also added a lot of
tools that are really
focused on apps, so that both
webmasters and app developers
can come to the search console
and get a really nice picture,
analytically, of what's
happening with your app
from the point of view of
Google Search-- what traffic
is flowing from Google
that's coming into your app.
And let's look at
some of the results
that some of our
partners are seeing.
Now, it's early days, but these
are kind of some early results,
but really exciting
for our app partners.
The Guardian--
what they're seeing
is that, for users that have
the Guardian app installed,
and that therefore are
seeing app links in Google
Search instead of
web links, they're
seeing a significant increase in
the clickthrough of those users
to go into the app, as opposed
to users to select the Guardian
website.
So a 4.5% jump of
that backclick.
So a nice increase
in reengagement.
Etsy, they've seen increased
traffic from referrals,
things that are flowing through
Google to them, of over 11%.
And Tabelog, who is a
Japanese restaurant app,
is seeing increased app traffic
to their restaurant pages,
so kind of the
core content pages,
the core purpose of
their app, of almost 10%.
So, again, early
days, but pretty
nice results for something
that's completely free
and that is easy for apps to do.
So where are we
going with all this?
Well, Jonathan mentioned that
cross-platform is incredibly
important for us at Google.
We understand that
your app needs
to work across these
different platforms.
And so we actually announced--
I think it was on Wednesday--
and began rolling out our
iOS approach to, or solution
for, app indexing.
And on iOS we've started
sort of the same way
we started on Android,
which is we worked
with a great set of partners--
you see their icons here--
to do the initial launch.
And we're just kind of
checking that, making sure
all the pipes are running
smoothly, and so on.
And then we'll open this up
to everyone in not very long.
I'm also very happy
to announce today
that we are opening
up app indexing
two apps that only exist as
apps and not as websites.
So far, what we've
done is really
work on it with apps that have
a corresponding web presence.
But there are a lot of
great apps in the world,
and probably many
of you are making
them, that don't have
corresponding web
presence, that still
provide wonderful content
and services for our users.
What this project
allows us to do
is bring those apps
into our index as well.
So things like HotelTonight,
Visual Anatomy Free,
and several others are kind
of our initial partners here.
Here we're going to be launching
this initial set of partners,
again, just to get
the pipes cleaned out
and make sure that
everything's working
within the next few weeks,
and then later in the year
we'll open this up for everyone.
And we're really
excited about this
because we think
it really will open
the floodgates to
letting any app be
a part of Google's index.
So hopefully I've convinced you
that a great way for your app
to get to be discovered
and reengaged with users
is through Google Search and
through indexing your app.
Allowing users to come to
Google and express a need
to find the great content
and the great service
inside your app.
We're seeing a lot
of effectiveness
here for app developers.
It's completely free, and if
you want to learn more about it,
you see the link here with
lots of documentation,
and also the box talk that
comes right after this.
Thanks very much, and
I'll bring back Jonathan.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Thanks, Scott.
It's incredible to
see all of this work
that Scott and his team are
doing to really bring apps
to life within the core of
what Google has to offer
the world-- our search product.
Seeing apps as first
class citizens,
and searching all of
this great deep linking
technology across
both platforms,
brings the biggest
smile to my face,
because it just shows
this commitment.
And it shows how
much more we're going
to be able to do in
this mobile world
when we really combined
the great power that Google
Search has to offer with
this wonderful content
that you guys are all creating
in these millions of apps.
We're going to pivot now.
We're going to
spend the last 10,
15 minutes or so talking
about paid advertising
and talking about
some of the solutions
that Google is
bringing to the front.
It's really aimed at making
it easier for all of you
from an advertising standpoint
to reach those users, to reach
them effectively, to reach the
high value users that you need
to, and to automate that
as much as possible,
bringing them into your app.
Scott's history about
Google, about the work
that we did to really bring
websites to life, web search
to life, is an analogy that
I want to draw on as well.
Because, if we think
about paid ads at Google,
we've generally
followed along with what
our friends on the
organic side have done.
Yes, we do have our usual
church and state policies,
but we've tried to
make the ads that we
show to users as
native, as integrated
in our experience as possible.
If you go all the way
back to 2002, 2003,
this was the very
inception of AdWords,
of Search ads on Google.
And we're doing the same
thing here with apps.
We're essentially
following that history
and following that path.
And we're using a
lot of the lessons
that we've learned
over the last 15 years
to bring app
advertising to Google
in much the same way that we
brought website advertising.
This brings me to
app install ads.
So we have app install ads as
an offering today across just
about all of our channels.
Between Search, Display,
YouTube, in-app.
And we try to make it as
easy as possible for you
guys to create these creatives,
to get them distributed,
to get these ads
targeted and put
in front of the eyeballs
of the right users,
so that you're driving
high-value lifetime
users to your application.
Perhaps the most
exciting announcement
that we've made in this
space over the last-- well,
I think since we even got
started in app advertising,
is the fact that we are now in
the process of bringing ads,
Search ads, to the Play Store.
We've currently been running
a beta, an early pilot,
with a number of advertisers.
This is going extremely well.
If you think about
it, the Play Store
captures the very
moment of intent
when a user knows that she needs
a certain mobile application
to solve a problem, the
task that she has laid out
before her.
And you see a couple
of examples here.
When this launches, we will
show at most one ad at the top.
It will be clearly labeled
as such, as we always have.
And, again, we're
seeing great results
both for users and
advertisers as we're
rolling this pilot out.
We're going to expand
the coverage of this.
We're going to get this
in all of your hands,
really, in the next
couple of months.
So keep an eye on this
as we roll it out.
YouTube has been another
phenomenal channel
for app promotion.
We started working with
our YouTube friends
a lot more closely
on this last year,
and we really brought
some of these ads
to life around the
middle of 2014.
It's still early days for
app promotion on YouTube,
but the results, as far as
our advertisers are concerned,
have been phenomenal.
The engagement is
incredibly rich.
The amount of eyeballs and users
they intersect with on YouTube
is massive.
And I think this next quote
really sums it up best.
So Deepak is a good
friend of ours,
and he's the Chief Revenue
Officer at Machine Zone.
Machine Zone is one of
the largest mobile games,
from a user and revenue
perspective, in the world.
And if Deepak knows
anything, Deepak really
knows how to acquire users and
how to acquire them at scale.
And any of you who've
done this, or who've
done it for a large
audience, know
that you need to really
embrace all of the channels
that you have.
And Machine Zone and
Deepak really do that.
They have tried just about
all of the channels that
are out there.
So to hear this
feedback from him,
the YouTube provides users that
are 15% more valuable than he
can get from any
other video platform,
to me says a hell of a lot.
And this is why advertisers
are clamoring more and more
for access to this
great YouTube inventory.
We're trying to make
it easy as well.
Because, as we introduce
all of these new channels--
Search, Display, YouTube,
Play Store-- the last thing
you're going to
want to have to do
is sit there and
hand-craft your campaigns
to make sure they work for
each and every one of these.
So our first step in
simplicity and automation
is what we're showing
on the screen here.
Earlier this year, we launched
the ability for advertisers
to extend their existing
AdMob in-app app promotion
campaigns to the mobile web.
What we do is we
take all of that
carefully crafted
targeting criteria
that you have so
carefully assembled
for your in-app promotions, and
we take it and we lift that up
and we drop it over to
the mobile web space.
So we can find your
users that are roughly as
valuable at roughly
the same CPI,
but in the mobile web
rather than in-app.
And this enables you to find new
unique users that you wouldn't
have acquired otherwise.
And advertisers are
seeing stunning results,
if you ask me.
Through nothing more
than a checkbox,
advertisers are
extending their reach
and are acquiring roughly 30%
more unique users with nothing
more than that checkbox.
So as we started to see
the success of this,
and we thought more and more
about automation at scale,
we wondered if we could
take this one step further.
And that's really
where we came up
with this concept for
universal app campaigns.
Why stop with the connection
between the AdMob network
and the mobile web network?
Why not automate this at scale
for as many advertisers as
possible?
Universal app
campaigns, which has
been in beta and early pilot
for the last couple of quarters
and is rolling out to all of you
in the next couple of months,
gives app promoters and app
developers the simplest way
to acquire valuable
users at scale.
We're talking about
roughly three inputs
from the advertiser
or the app developer.
You got to tell me
what your app is;
we can go then and find
all the great information
we need to about your app.
You got to tell me
how much money you're
willing to put into the
system, what your budget is.
And then you have to give
me some characteristics
about the type of
users you want to find,
but this isn't heavy-handed
targeting criteria.
This is like, find
me roughly users
at this CPI or this
target lifetime value.
And that's it.
We do the rest.
And for those of
you at the keynote
yesterday, you understand the
power of the machine learning
technology, the artificial
intelligence and machine
learning technology,
that we have at Google.
And we essentially take those
handful of inputs from you,
and we use our bidding
algorithms, our automation
algorithms, these massive
machine learning systems,
to scan across all of these
different networks between Play
and YouTube and Google
Search and AdMob.
And we work to find the next
cheapest install, agnostic
of channel, that satisfies
that goal that you've
set out for us.
The results have
been incredible.
Advertisers have to do very,
very little effort here
and are finding that this
scales much, much better
than individual campaigns.
Because they're able
to find-- the best
way to think about this is,
we can acquire a set of users
for you very, very cheaply on
the search side of the world.
I think about when
those navigational type
queries come in.
That's an exact match; it's
a very low cost per install.
But then in order to truly
grow your volume in search,
you may find that you
see a significant step up
in price from a cost
per install perspective.
What Universal App campaigns is,
is it helps us spread that out.
So we might find that next
tranche of cheaper users
to acquire sits in
the AdMob space,
or maybe on the Play Store.
And our bidding
algorithms can work
across all of these
different properties
to maximize the number of users
we acquire for you at the least
cost possible.
We are incredibly excited
about what we're building here,
and we hope all of you
in the audience try it.
One of the things that's really
a benefit to us at Google,
as we approach this
app promotion space,
is the fact that, for the
better part of the last 15 years
or so, we've been working
on ads-targeting technology.
And we bring all of that
to bear in this apps space.
I was talking about
our machine learning,
and the key algorithm that
we use in the ad space
is something called
Conversion Optimizer.
Very simply,
Conversion Optimizer
works to maximize the
number of conversions--
in this case, installs--
that we can deliver
to an advertiser,
given a certain price
or given a target
cost per acquisition.
For the app space, we've tuned
those conversion optimized
models to take into account
all kinds of signals
about our users as they
sit on our platforms.
So we can do these
kinds of things.
We can bid higher
for users who we
believe are more
inclined to make
an in-app purchase overall.
So if you're a
game developer, you
rely on IAP to
make a living, you
want to find users who are going
to spend money in your app.
So we start to be able
to identify these,
and we know they're more
valuable and will bid higher.
We can go even further, though.
We can start to predict-- we can
actually do this quite well--
we can predict the probability
that a particular user,
an individual user, will
actually purchase in your app.
I got to tell you-- when I
talk app developers and game
developers about this
specific technology,
I mean, their wallets
come out almost instantly.
It's like, well, if you can
deliver me paying users,
I'm willing to pay
whatever it takes.
And this is the core of
what we're focused on when
we talk about app promotion.
And we do things
like expanding reach
as well, if that is helpful.
We can bid lower, but we can
bring more low-cost users
in if you want volume.
The results are extraordinary.
When we do this right,
campaigns that leverage
this technology
are 24 times more
likely to generate a buyer.
And therefore, the cost of
acquiring a buyer drops by 90%.
Because, if you're interested
in buyers and only buyers,
you're wasting a lot of
money bringing non-buyers
into the equation.
Acquiring users acquiring
valuable users at scale--
isn't the only thing
you need to do here.
You absolutely need to
understand your data.
You need to understand
the performance,
you need to understand what's
working and what isn't.
Because, ultimately,
it's you're were dollars
that you're paying to
acquire these users,
and you want to
make sure that those
are invested the best possible.
The thing that really
stuns me and my team--
we've been out talking about
the importance of analytics
in apps for the better part of
the last four years-- and yet,
still, our surveys indicate
that only 21% of app developers
actually use some form
of analytic solution.
I have no idea how the
other 79% of app developers
run their businesses.
So we really implore you
to use an analytic solution
of some kind.
And I'm going to spend
a few minutes talking
about our analytic solution
for this, which is Google
Analytics for mobile apps.
Now, Google Analytics has been
working on mobile app solutions
for the last two to three
years, and they're really,
really becoming quite robust.
On the buy side now,
Google Analytics
gives you access to all of these
core app-user-based concepts--
things like lifetime
value reporting.
In this example, you understand
the value of users in aggregate
as they spend a longer and
longer time on your app.
And eventually it asymptotes
to roughly lifetime value here
of about $9, but you also see
how that increases over time.
Cohort analysis is
pretty interesting,
because it breaks
this down by days.
A lot of larger
app developers are
starting to do things like run
TV ad campaigns in conjunction
with what they're doing online.
And that's an
example you see here
where there might have been a TV
campaign run on the February 4
date, which is what's
driving higher retention.
You need to understand
how external events might
be changing the types of
users that you're acquiring
and might be changing how those
users engage with your app.
ARPU, of course
is a key concept--
sorry, average
revenue-per-user, or ARPU,
is a key concept to most app
developers care an awful lot
about.
I want to know how much
value each user's driving
in aggregate.
It also helps you think about
how you should be targeting
your cost per install,
because in order
to get a positive ROI
back out of the system,
you can't be paying more to
acquire users than they're
driving back to you.
Jason Titus made a number
of announcements on stage
yesterday about our approach
in this mobile analytics world,
and I want to reinforce
those right now.
Our analytics team
understands how important
it is that they remain neutral.
And one of the key
ways to enable that,
and to show you that we're
really trying to be neutral
and to be agnostic to the media
you buy or the media you track
or the tools you use,
is we're continuing
to pursue an incredibly
transparent, open, and reliable
approach to mobile analytics.
And we are committed to this.
We are incredibly
committed to this.
Our mobile app analytics
tools-- Google Analytics now
supports iOS conversion tracking
across over 20 ad networks
that you see behind me here.
So Google Analytics
integrates, not
just with networks like
the Google Search network
or Google Search
or AdMob, but also
all of these networks on iOS.
And we integrate with a
number of these networks
on the Android side as well.
We've got to stay open,
we've got to say flexible,
and we've got to be as
transparent as possible
to continue to grow
this vibrant ecosystem.
Many of you who care about
tracking installs and value
across a variety of
different networks
use third-party
measurement partners.
These are good friends of
ours, like the folks at Tune
and Kochava as well as Adjust.
We've been working very, very
closely with all these folks
and more to make
sure that you can
use these third-party
tools as reliably as you
would use Google Analytics.
You can now integrate your
third-party measurement tools
tracking and reports
directly into AdWords.
And our teams have been working
with the brilliant teams
at these companies for
the past couple of months
to make sure that the data
that's being pumped in
is as robust and
reliable as possible.
To summarize, you've got to
think about all of the ways
that you can get users
to engage with your app,
that you can get discovered.
Because remember-- there
are so many apps out there,
and it is so hard to
rise above the noise.
Scott talked about a
number of incredible ways
that you can leverage
all of these free tools
that we offer you on the
search side of the world.
It's amazing to
see how much we've
done-- it's amazing to
see our commitment there--
but definitely think about all
of the app indexing techniques
that Scott talked about.
Because users are
coming to Google
Search on their mobile
phones more than
they ever have before.
And when they look for content
that you've got in your app,
you should be that top result.
Remember that you can use
AdWords for app promotion,
that we're working to make
it damn simple for all of you
to reach as many users at scale
across all of our platforms
as possible while still
driving the maximum value.
And lastly-- first, make sure
you're leveraging some kind
of analytics tool, because
you're crazy if you don't.
And second, remember that we
have Google Analytics, which
is free, is robust,
integrates with a variety
of third-party ad networks,
and is available to all of you
today.
And we continue to show that
commitment towards openness
and extension to embracing
our partnerships by showcasing
that all of our friends with
these third-party measurement
tools-- again, like
Tune and Kochava--
can integrate directly
now into AdWords.
We hope you're as excited as
we are about all of these tools
that we've released
over the last few weeks
to really give you
the power to drive
your apps, your
businesses, at scale.
With that, we'd
like to thank you
all for your time and
your attention today.
Have a great rest of your
time at Google I/O. Take care.
[APPLAUSE]